take the opportunity that's given to you
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent add something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I started the one rule
series because I watch a lot of top tens
we compile a lot of different videos
together and sometimes the same rule
comes up over and over and over again so
that's the goal with this series to
smoosh together the most popular rules
so today we're gonna learn how you can
seize every opportunity also if you want
to know what Eric Thomas Gary Vaynerchuk
myself and other entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a 30
second to five minute video for free
every day to help you build your
confidence check out the link in the
description below
what I've been telling you to get that
gold get that dream and I'm just having
telling you drive it and drive it and
drive it and drive it what I've been
talking about is consistency and for
some of you for real for real you'll
never have it you'll never be it you'll
never do it because you don't have any
consistency on a bigger macro
patience and failure they all ladder up
to one thing which is insecurity the
reason people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much realising
that any big endeavor is the collection
of a lot of small steps that came before
and so trying to break down whatever
that big thing is that you want to do
that seemed so scary and crazy and out
of this world and not possible and not
within your skill set are ever gonna
happen for you find whatever the
smallest first step is and then the
smallest next step is and continue to
build those steps and when you look back
you'll have realized that you made some
pretty significant progress stop saying
I'm not good enough stop saying my
family we don't do this like stop with
the excuses and take the opportunity
that's given to you shoot the doggone
shot you wide open take this shot I need
you to hear me very carefully
when he told me I would be great I never
shared this with my friends but I will
wake up in that abandoned building and I
would pretend that I was gonna be great
as I walked up and down those lonely
streets I would pretend to myself that I
was gonna be great I need you to be a
failure before the actual dream
reality I need you to wake up every
single day I need you to eat the dream I
need you to sleep the dream I need you
to talk to tree because some days you
not gonna feel like getting up and the
dream is gonna push you some day you're
not gonna feel like keep going but the
dream is going to push you technology
and the way we live doesn't care about
my opinion or my feelings and it doesn't
care about yours either and so you can
walk around earth and judge oh it's so
sad that all these kids can't
communicate cuz they're on the phone
anymore and you could talk about a day
and age when it was simpler and nicer
and all this nobody gives up and if you
don't adjust to the reality of the
situation you will be completely left
behind too many people are executing or
hoping or trying to figure out how to
live in a world that used to be or the
way they wish it was versus attacking
the reality of the world and here is the
reality of the world my friends the cell
phones that you're all holding right now
or in your pocket are the remote
controls of our society they are the
single most important thing in the world
there's nothing close whatever you want
to happen in life you first need
somebody's attention and then you should
tell them about it it was called the
newspaper the television and the radio
now it's called a blog a vlog or a
podcast
it's the same thing nothing's changed
except one thing your attention is
moving to a new place and leaving an old
place I'm making this very simple very
black-and-white very basic if you do not
spend next year completely obsessing
over how you become successful on
Facebook and Instagram you will be
disproportionately less likely to win
the ad product on those two platforms
are disproportionally underpriced
and that that is where you should be
trading you are grossly under estimating
what's happening right now 98% of people
are grossly under estimating how good it
is right you will look back at this talk
all my content during this era why am i
producing so much content during this
era
and speaking to this subject it's
because I know what I'm talking about
right now is gonna go away
and I think we can all agree I'm not
hedging up here right now I'm
desperately trying to force this down
your mouth right you heard it and I
believe that 95% of you will not do
anything about it you'll do enough to
make it feel like you did something and
you will regret not going all-in how
many people here play poker good I don't
but if you do when you have the best
hand it's a good idea to go all-in
I'd like you to fast-forward to 70 80 90
years old right fast forward in your
mind to that age 70 80 90 100 110 if
you're really optimistic whichever one
it is and I'd like you to write down
what will be the things that you regret
that you didn't do
imagine you're that age ask yourself the
question what will I regret that I
didn't do know what you did do but what
you didn't do
write it down make a long list right now
get a pen and paper out and write it
down don't do on your phone don't do on
your laptop actually get a pen and paper
and write down your answers and what
will be the things that you regret that
you didn't do right really think about
it would it be you know learning a new
language will it be moving home will it
be telling someone you love them what
will it be what would have been write it
down right now now the incredible thing
about this question is that you're using
the future to empower the past whatever
answer you have in that question
whatever your answer is you can do it
right now today starting today because
you're not that agent and if you're even
if you're 64 and you're tuning in 70 80
90 you're still there right it's still
possible you can start doing that right
now it's empowering the present with the
future there is nothing stopping you
from making it happen right now you
don't have to feel that way when you're
70 you don't have to feel that way when
you're 80 you never ever have to feel
that way if you start doing it right now
and you can do it right now even if it
feels impossible you can stop working
now you can start trying right now you
can start making plans right now because
you're not there yet
and this is where you start this is
where you start making it happen it's
all in the now a lot of people see the
idea of being entrepreneurs or being our
own bosses are building their own
empires this thing that you know you
need investments you need all these
people need to flip flip right look if
this sock costs five dollars to make we
sell it for twenty dollars you make
fifteen dollars flip with rocking with
you know I was trying to keep with rocky
for a long time she's Spanish and you
know Puerto Rican girls they can't bring
black boys home old school you know I'm
saying right so it took a minute you
know saying or and she just told me
curveballs left and right and so one of
her curveballs was you know I see put
all these other people on you know I see
you make all these other people's dreams
come true but you like to make movies I
can't get with you unless you stand
behind what you love and I was like all
right you know I had to you know I mean
she called me out you know I'm saying so
it was like you know I can't have my
woman or girl I want to be my woman
calling me out but also it made perfect
sense it was true I was unconsciously
probably standing behind other people
instead of standing behind myself all I
do is get somebody and tell them how to
get it and you know make the things that
are wrong right but if I can make the
things that are wrong right for somebody
else why not sell me you know understand
like even down to the diabetes I'm like
yo yeah we do a whole network on
diabetes something that's usually
considered a weakness I'd prefer to turn
it into a strength
it's about me first day what I'm saying
you need to hustle while you wait if you
can embody this advice and apply it to
your business on a day to day basis this
will be the biggest momentum shift in
your company this will move you so close
to your goals at an incredible pace that
is unbelievable just most people don't
do it hustle while you wait
listen with every goal that you have it
relies on other people you need other
people to be a part of your process
right if you're selling to customers you
need the customer to say yes they have
to make the
decision there's a bunch of
back-and-forth if you're waiting on a
product to come you're waiting on your
supplier to come forward this there's
always things that are outside your
control that you're waiting other people
for and yes when it comes to you you
want to get it done as soon as possible
if a customer is asking for a quote you
want to get it off your plate ASAP you
should not be the bottleneck in momentum
happening in your business that's a
whole other problem as soon as that that
comes to you it's getting taken care of
and you're building momentum but you're
still even at the most peak efficiency
waiting for other people to take action
that's gonna happen so what do you do in
those moments you hustle you build new
momentum you build new clients you build
new relationships you maintain the
existing ones and get everything done as
soon as possible and then in the
downtime while you're waiting for a
decision
you're not just twiddling your thumbs
you know just sitting on the couch
you're not watching Netflix you're off
hustling new business quick example I
was doing a photo shoot with Richard
this guy's celebrity photographer he's
done Lady gaga done the whole bunch of
rappers he came over and we did a photo
shoot together and in between his shots
he's gonna set up lights he's gotta get
his fog machine going he's gotta get the
right angle he's got to set up the
green-screen
and so when he needs me I'm there I'm
ready I'm posing I'm in action I'm ready
to go but there's a lot of setup in
between shots and so what am i doing I'm
pulling out my phone and I'm responding
to you guys I'm making videos I'm doing
responses I'm getting on Twitter and
Instagram I'm doing on snapchat I'm
sending out video responses to you guys
I'm working I'm hustling on my downtime
while I'm waiting for Rich for this
project I am hustling connecting with
you guys and that's the approach that
you need to take people say well how do
I find the time to respond to people on
social media I probably have a way
bigger cats and you guys do and I find
the time because I make the time in
between the other things that I'm doing
this is so critical people are losing so
much time the answer is not to wake up
two hours early or think that's gonna
solve your problem the answer is your
Lou
same time every single day you are
leaking valuable time from your daily
schedule and so I highly highly highly
encourage you to take this message home
while you are working while people are
waiting on you for stuff you are doing
your best to deliver as soon as possible
so that you are not the bottleneck in
your business but then while you're
awaiting other people you get your
hustle on you continue to build momentum
it is such a hack to get you closer to
achieving the goals that you have for
yourself stop sleeping while you're
waiting for the people to get back to
you hustle
while you wait you started out at the
comedian correct no I started out as a
straight actor how it's right I couldn't
get any work because people would look
and I'd go try to do some Shakespeare
and they'd go
what are you here for and I'd say well
I'd like to audition for they go no no
no no no next so I wrote a whole bunch
of stuff for me to do so I could show
people what I was capable of and that
sort of kicked everything off I'm
someone who's self-employed when I
worked for before I was self-employed I
worked for large organizations and if
you had asked me when I work for the
Washington Post say would I ever want to
be self-employed I would have said
reacted with horror I would have thought
I can't understand how you could do that
don't you wake up every morning in a
cold sweat knowing where your next
dollar is coming from it turns out I'm
Way happier self-employed than I was
working for but I getting there took and
it you know it took 20 years it took all
kinds of lucky breaks into Caulkins if
there was no one in my life who I didn't
know any self-employed people I didn't
know how to make that kind of jump and I
you know I wonder what how many people
are in a similar position of not
realizing they have the ability to be do
something entrepreneurial and would be
happier doing something entrepreneur but
just have no example December 10th 1914
there was a massive explosion in West
Orange New Jersey
see United States of America 10
buildings in a factory owned by the
legendary inventor Thomas Edison were
engulfed by flames six to eight fire
departments rushed to the scene but
could not curb the chemical fueled
inferno
after having dried all that he could as
Thomas Edison calmly stood there
watching the fire destroy his entire
life's hard work his 24 year old son
Charles came over and stood next to him
and a childlike voice Edison said to his
son Charlie go and get your mother and
her friends they'd never be able to see
a spectacular fire like this in their
entire life
astonished and shocked by spiders
response Charles asked Thomas Edison
our entire Factory is being burnt down
to ashes bed Thomas Edison replied in
complete composure yes
our factory is being burnt down to ashes
but all the mistakes we've made so far
in the factory have also been burnt down
to ashes we will start all over again
tomorrow that evening Thomas Edison told
a New York Times reporter although I'm
67 years old and I'm completely
exhausted from running around and trying
to control the file tomorrow I'll start
all over again
afresh and so he did the next day was a
fresh beginning for Thomas Edison and
his son Charles in trying to rebuild
what had been destroyed by the fire
often this is what life does unto us our
dreams are shattered our hopes broken
efforts baffled great people they don't
cry they try to rebuild their dreams
great people don't give up live up to
the challenges that life throws at them
great people don't go through they grow
through the difficulties that come on
their path they start all over again
with great hope with great determination
with great great
and that is why they reach the highest
peaks of success that most people only
aspire for that is why I say no
challenges no success no challenges no
success what was actually your first job
in the business when you sort of knew
you wanted to be an actor first job in
America or first you know just as an
actress yeah it was this indie film shot
on the Gold Coast which is where I'm
from in Australia and it never got
released or I've never even seen it like
it was very very low budget like lower
than an indie film but more like a
student film sort of thing but it was a
thriller sort of thing called I see you
do you worry it's not worried but do you
expect it to come out any day now I it
was a chance to be on a film set no
matter how small the set was it was
still film set and that was like a dream
come true could you ever imagine what
water came out of your original
entrepreneurial steps no I could not
possibly have imagined but you know and
I I don't know what your thinking was
behind the form but I remember when I
was really thinking deeply about this
and this was sort of a you know a
graduate student project at Stanford and
I talked to my advisors like you know
should I really do this entrepreneurial
thing and you know might not work out
and I could just finished my PhD and he
said you know why not go for it and then
it doesn't work out you come back you
finish your PhD which I'm still planning
on doing but anyway you know there's
like no big deal just give it a shot and
and I think that that mentality
permeates Silicon Valley and I think
that's one of those strengths that you
know there's really not much it's not
viewed so negatively to try something
even if it doesn't work out
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Eric Thomas on how to find your
gift that I think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions I want you
to move from not just watch another
video but to actually taking action in
your life or in your business so with
these three questions think about them
yourself
talk about them with a friend or write
your answers down in the comments below
here we go question number one what
current challenge can you see as an
opportunity question number two what do
you need to take your shot on today a
question number three what will you do
to stay motivated to work on your goal
everyday thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is
much love see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
when did you know hey this is something
different about me I can really speak
here this is something unique freshman
year in college don't laugh alright
freshman year in college me and my boys
start like this like Christian like
organizations or every Tuesday Thursday
and Sunday we'd speak now they didn't
let me speak initially okay because I
was a high school dropout rough around
the edges like I wasn't really polished
right and so but here's a good thing is
you know you stay home was a gift so we
did it every Tuesday Thursday Sunday so
at some point the guys couldn't make the
appointment so so I was like always the
host of the show so when they didn't
show up yes they like what we bring in
solar so to speak I'm like no no you're
not
I'm hosted so this much right here the
best of villain ability is availability
right everyone their tray wedding there
I'm like finally three four months into
it I'm like I'm no I'm here cuz they got
hair you know and my first message was
pimpin ain't easy but somebody's got to
do it that's my first master church
meeting you had to church me i pimpin it
easy but somebody's got to do it I said
don't laugh but but this is how I knew I
had something because people were like
yo
nobody's ever and so I talked about how
the devil is trying to pimp us and and
you know and I just took that whole
angle and my second message just blew up
was how many licks does it take to get
to the center of a sucker you know and
so everybody was just like yo rut it's
different like this is not a normal
preacher it's not the normal delivery
the energy is kind of different
so why adults weren't really fooling
with me a lot of guys who were like oh
we only do that Church stuff like we
don't do that kind of stuff we're not
into that and what was unique about and
I'm glad you asked nobody's ever asked
for this what was unique is that we did
at the bell tower which was in the
center of the campus so you had to pass
it to go anywhere so it's cast like you
I wasn't coming to no spiritual event
but I would hear that loud voice and
that passengers and I heard
you know so they would just walk over
like yeah what is he talking about
pimping ain't easy and it was at that
point when I saw non church regular
people jeans t-shirts coming by and when
I would speak stop I was like yo e you
got you got something yeah you got some
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I'm
saying it's a bloody brief life all of
you have the potential for enormous
success if you want to know what gary
vee DJ khalid oprah and others know
about empire building that most people
miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video